there was an interesting medical study
on what what happens to people after
they die are people coming back to life
are they getting to that great white
light let's take a look a scientist at
the University of Southampton have spent
four years examining more than 2,000
people who suffered cardiac arrest in
the UK US and Austria nearly 40% of
people who survived describe some kind
of awareness during the time when they
were clinically dead before their hearts
were restarted 13% they had felt
separated from their bodies and their
senses had been heightened that we've
got a couple more findings for you one
man recalled leaving his body entirely
watching his resuscitation from the
corner of the room
despite being unconscious and dead for
three minutes he recounted the actions
of the nursing staff in detail and
described the sound of the machines so
we hear about this stuff all the time
John's already shaking his head no I
know I've got another sceptic in Kim but
we hear about this stuff all the time
and you know I guess there really is no
way of knowing right people aren't
coming back from the dead but it's an
interesting thing to think about and to
talk about yes interesting look I love
the idea of like resurrection things
like that I think that's very
interesting but the thing that always
strikes me about these near-death
experiences or likes consciousness after
death is that they're always so
provincial like they always have the
same sense as humans have they see
things and they hear things even in the
animal kingdom there are other senses
than that they're there you know there
is echolocation their sensitivity to
magnetic wait like they never had any
new information they only have the same
sort of information a human suspended
from the ceiling could have right well I
guess there's still humans at that point
even if they're transient we don't get
spiritual beings their trend lives
transcendent okay so John's given a
pretty sound scientific explanation of
why maybe this isn't real but are some
things just beyond science something
like this is beyond what can be measured
scientifically right I read this article
and I thought okay that's interesting
perhaps the brain is able to react more
than we thought beyond our current
medical standards I didn't read that as
paranormal life after death that's just
it's further of our understanding of I
suppose the human brain or perhaps how
our triggers stimuli works when we were
approaching death I don't think that's
any sign of anything paranormal or
spiritual yeah so I think it does bring
up some interesting points because if we
could somehow prove this or quantify
that something actually is happening it
would change how we do end-of-life
things right like euthanasia and keeping
up people alive on machines you might
want to extend people's like if they
were in some sort of alternate universe
or whatever you want to call so it could
change what how we treat life right or
in the opposite direction if you knew
that there was some life after death you
might just offer yourself and want to
experience that I mean for people who
have a shitty situation right now but
feel like this is all they have if they
knew they'd become some sort of floating
Wraith being maybe they would want to
kill themselves if they could prove it
I would I would love that I would talk
about it on my show constantly it's just
at this point I don't think that these
sorts of experiences necessarily provide
article calls it biggest-ever scientific
study this is a scientific study because
we're there properly controlled
conditions oh it's a study right there
it's all self-reported and you know
perhaps we're experiencing things in the
human mind that we might not normally
experience were more close to death when
we have this visceral reaction of I am
going to die and you know perhaps the
subconscious becomes more aware I don't
know but it's great to study and I think
it does require more study so is that
the part of it that's really the
intriguing part is that fundamentally we
will never know and because we'll never
know we have to it's it sort of
prescribes whatever your life whatever
your life meaning is you can prescribe
to whatever the afterlife is because
they're not going to show you a paper
one day and say this is what happens
it's just not gonna happen yeah or at
least not anytime soon yeah I think
you're right I think that for people who
who aren't particularly scientifically
minded or those who are an area where
science can't yet tread is definitely
interesting and it provides fertile
ground for a lot of interesting
hypothesizing final thought and this is
the meaning of life question do you
think it would take something out of
life if we knew what it was all about
you know if we
knew that there was an afterlife do you
think it would somehow destination yeah
does it take some of the meaning out of
what we're doing here because to me it
seems like we're I don't know what the
hell is going on after this thing I'm
not even sure what's happening now but
we're here so I do the best I can you
know so I think you would fundamentally
lose something if you actually did know
what was going on in here well John's
point about the continuous ritual
suicide might become a thing unless you
know your religion says don't commit
suicide but yeah I very much feel that
the journey is more important the
destination my life is probably more
important than whatever is after my life
because I can feel this and I can see
this I know it's here and I should be
able to put some meaning into it yeah
yeah I think that for some people it
definitely would but I mean even if as a
teenager you're well aware of the fact
that you're gonna be an adult at some
point that doesn't mean that you just
disregard your teen years I mean you
still have to experience it you still
learn from it and grow so I would hope
that people by the time we had proof
would be advanced enough to not be
overly swayed by the proof